I tried making aeroplane jokes but they
flew right over people's heads have you
ever thought why most of the aeroplanes
are painted white with over thousands of
colors to choose from
why only white doesn't the spark a sense
of curiosity with the new well if it did
let's try curbing it in this Q Buzzard
[Music]
for getting into the details of this Q
pisode let me ask you a question in
summers why do we usually prefer wearing
white clothes that's correct it's to
reduce the intensity of heat on our body
so now can you answer why planes are
painted in white yes it's also to reduce
the intensity of heat
let's understand this reason in detail
as the planes fly high in the sky they
are exposed to more sunlight and solar
radiation and we already know that it's
the white color which reflects more
light compared to any other color does
it helps in minimizing the heating and
also protecting the planes from any
potential damage from sunlight okay is
this the only reason not really did you
know that aeroplanes put on weight due
to paint yes I'm not kidding
painting on aeroplanes will result in
significant increase in its weight more
the weight of the aeroplanes more will
be their operating costs so what do you
think should be done here correct
reduce the weight so Aero planes are
painted on being bright and additional
colors are not used do you think white
color has any role to play in safety yes
it does an airplane undergoes a number
of safety checks before it takes off so
if there is any crack or surface damage
then it can be easily identified on the
white surface relative to any other
colored surface white color even helps
in spotting fluid leakage is that it not
really
another major advantage is that the
rescue team will be able to spot the
white aeroplane quickly in case of an
emergency
also the resale value of the white plane
is higher as the buyer will not have to
repaint the plane these were a lot of
reasons
and now we know the reasons why
aeroplanes are painted in white okay we
have one more instrument on the plane
which records all the activities of an
airplane during its flight can you help
me mimics no prizes for guessing it's
the black box the name says it's a black
box but what's the actual color of the
box is it black or is it some other
color this is your cue box to explore
let us know your findings in the comment
section below